yeah I think everyone uh thank you for
inviting me for this talk today I'll
talk about crowd basic processing of big
images so this is this Workshop is more
like Theory to practice and this is like
almost 90 practice and 10 Theory but it
will give very good motivation on why
should we be building such linear solver
right because today uh didn't throw the
course into this Workshop you you'll
hear about a lot of like work done but
there isn't much about talk about the
demand for such solvers and today we're
going to go through detail motivation
for image processing okay sometimes I'll
bring interaction most of you might not
know me I before I currently I'm a
member of clinical staff at the signal
processing lab and a defense science
organization in Singapore so we are like
the Army research or Naval Research
equivalent in Singapore so we work for
military and my personal interest in is
in compresses and sensing for Imaging
radar electric Optical satellites
exploitation and how to process image
quickly and previously I was from CMU I
worked with Gary enriched the previous
speaker
and the totally struck in the tree
portion one is the what is the Big Image
Challenge and how can we reformulate
this image processing task as graph
based problems and the last one is top
of practical approaches and challenges
to using media solvers in doing this
image processing tasks so now it has to
work big right so the thing that comes
to most of my is like big data this is
like the password today so we all know
when you talk about Big Data the things
we think about is like Google Amazon and
Facebook and if you Google right there
were big data and you realize that it's
represented by mostly blue pictures I do
not really know why but this is the
reality but what is Big Image okay so
the difference the biggest difference
between Big Image and big data is in big
data is highly unstructured you're
always given a bunch of data points and
your goal is to find the hidden
communities the structure underline this
all the generative model that's creating
this big data and there's a lot of
advance in the recent years such as deep
belief networks manifold learning
however for images and Signal processing
the the data we're looking at is very
highly structured the structure is
reversed the way we observe the world
and the way the Imaging sensors are
created so how can we explore this
underlying structure for efficient
computation and you probably would guess
that
structure is a graph right in fact it's
a very nice but obviously a Greek crop
so these are the sensors we have today
so they are big in terms of scale and
volume for example the worldview 3
satellites visuals launched launched
this year August and it's getting
ubiquitous and fast like your GoPro
cameras and the last one is on high
dimension we're looking at like light
fuel Imaging hyper spectral Imaging so
the image data will become high
dimension in the near future and the
goal today what is known as the
efficient computation in image
processing would be to process two
gigabyte of images under five minutes so
I do not produce numbers off if you go
and read uh like the US DARPA paper this
is usually the goal that it was State
because this translates to some kind of
Q change
there's a time required to like kill
someone okay so this is a currency of
the art by the US program so they have
this Gorgon stair 2 which is comprising
of 368 cameras and it sends us uh one
point eight billion pixels in at 12
frames per second so that translates
about 50 gigabytes per second and this
is a really larger than what your
gigabit internet can process
so so how do they actually get about
doing this so today they still what
people do is they actually take big
images they chop them up and they
parallel and they parallel process them
without having any notion of what is the
overview of the image itself so for
example this is a Google map
uh image right and you can see that
clearly there are seams from the part
where they actually partition the image
and they don't actually bother like
trying to glue them up because doing
that is quite hard so what we want to do
is to actually process the images as an
entire data cube in an efficient manner
so by doing that it gives a new
means of new novel ways of doing image
processing so we're going to do a
comparison from hyperlapse it's a
Microsoft C graph paper in this year and
the left side is a single frame
rendering the right side is a
multi-frame rendering so basically the
right size will be rendered based on the
entire data Cube itself
as you can see if you have the entire
data Cube you can actually compensate
for missing pixels way better than any
kind of electropic stabilization
software you have today and this is
built upon a few techniques or these
markup random View and personal blending
image personal blending Technologies
okay so that's the big image challenge
itself the Big Image challenge is to
process image data set globally in an
efficient manner okay so get better okay
so now let's before we can talk about
image processing let's talk about signal
processing so
um not everyone is familiar with single
protesting so I just added this bunch of
like one-on-one slides
if it's too boring and I apologize
anyway so the goal of every single
signal processing task is given a
centered signal it's usually uh
convolved with a transfer function and
then add it with some additive noise and
the goal is always to recover the signal
itself so we have like noisy leaner
which is a very famous picture in
computer vision and the goal is always
to try to denoise you know and if I give
you this as Lena and answer do you
believe this is the original leaner
answer the yes but why why would you say
yes because everyone has a notion a
private notion of what the structure of
the signal should be so we have an
inherent idea of what natural signal
should be
so if you uh and all of this EC actually
has uh oh sorry oh signal processing has
more or less like three flavors or
something so the first one is you if you
believe your signal is band limited then
you have your traditional Shannon Nikos
processing so almost all of electrical
engineering is based on that assumption
so we have filter designs everything is
based on the abandoned Shannon Nyquist
sampling rate it's all based on this
band limited assumption so battery meter
is that your signal has is Compact and
has finite support so that's the main
assumption but if you believe your
signal has finite support but Spas then
in 2006 uh there's two group of people
uh candies Rumble and Tau and Don Ho
independently discover this notion of
compressive sensing and this was already
mentioned by a few speakers in this
Workshop itself the comprehensive
sensing is another way to view single
processing where the signal is passed
and lastly if you believe there's
correlation in your signal itself then
we're gonna have a graph based approach
we will talk about in this talk
so before that you share some remarks of
conferences sensing since it's like the
really new topic and it uses a lot of L1
solvers and this potentially another
area which dissolves technology can go
over to so the main assumption is that
the signal itself is fast and they have
some minimal separation between the
signals so I'm sure you have here this
team a few times maybe like even a topic
modeling they tend to use this as well
so having these two assumptions are very
powerful because it allows you to reduce
the number of samples that you're
required to reconstruct the signal so
one of this very famous example is the
one pixel camera by Justin Romberg uh
Kelly and from The Institute of rice
where they just sense the whole world
using one single photo diode and they
can reconstruct as good as a normal 2D
two-dimensional array cameras
however there's one major caveat is that
if you are going to high and higher
resolutions you actually cannot beat the
true Shannon knickers bounds so what is
this is this due to a phenomenon as
coherence so if you're approaching to
the physical limit of the sensor there
is this phenomenon as coherence which
forbids you from actually beating the
shenanigos rate so what it means is that
at the end of the day right if you
really want to have high resolution
images you'll pretty much stuck at
processing all the pixels again
so yeah so which gives some motivation
why should we carry on work in all the
blood solvers
okay so let's we're going to talk uh
talk through how do you transform image
processing problems into graph based
problems so we start with one very
famous pretty famous functional known as
the market shot
tonight so it is given an image or
and a model j and some boundary D so the
function is written as this form so
if there's a square difference
between the model
the image and model and the this is
actually correct it's actually the
square of the gradients and the last one
is a the connected components the
boundary of the model model itself so
it's essentially is there are three
terms right Fidelity smoothness and
component so any some combination on
this actually produce a different kind
of image processing algorithm so if we
take
the one with the connected component you
get some uh the Chan versus segmentation
algorithm then the one we're going to
talk about today is actually the TV
variational denoising so the RF 92 model
or routine is
even a noisy image as our goal is to
recover X right and the functional is
okay we have seen a few times already
this function appearing so it's the
square B2 Norm of the difference and the
absolute or the one Norm of the
recovered pixel difference so what this
translates to is actually you're
applying a gaussian noise prior
and you're having a prior of uh the the
age having laplacian distribution
so this came actually naturally from the
Muffler shot functional so
this is just some interesting it was
actually designed for guiding
was actually designed to guide weapons
so in case you don't know that most of
the English programming was designed to
drop bombs
so the thing is that the TV is uh this
stock is a really no dysfunction has
it's been mentioned a few times in the
top and it belongs to a class of well
it's not as bounded variational problems
so interestingly a lot of the image
processing tiles has a bounded version
of functional the reason being because
the convergence for this set of this
family or functionals is very well very
well known well studied so if you can
write this uh you'll notice that like
cementation like level set segmentation
stuff like that they all have a bounded
original function somewhere in it to
ensure convergence
so the TV
it was designed RF 92 was designed in a
heavy tour
um
in 2001 I had the published in
jacministrative segmentation that showed
that if these functions are convex
which is the fastest possible so for
instance the
with the image that you show three
slides ago the function that you have
there is solved as a minimum carbon
graph right if the deviation is any
convex function it's called parametric
carbon graph and the running time is the
best possible in Quantum improving so I
don't see how you can relate to this all
of these and later papers and the
results they'll dominate all of them
yeah this is not this is why it's not
saying that these are fast run time well
this is what I'm trying to say is a
movement towards from interior Point
matters to using
the
linear systems itself
so this is like not talking about this
is not a compressible runtime right but
these are TV outgoing and this one is
also a TV algorithm yeah I agree but
this one this was designed specifically
for TV denoising
so I think girls solve a larger class of
problems
the difference is that the isomet
isometric or analysis
is
the point this slide is not saying the
method to solve the TBD but this
algorithms were specifically designed to
solve the TBD problem I would believe
you that your algorithms saw a larger
set of problems
but it's also the running time is best
possible this this whole area is not
talking about running time you it's more
about what was the was this
this cell slice right we're not going to
say that this is the fastest running
time but it's more like what was the
movement from trying to solve these
problems this is more like the intuition
rather than the running time comparison
foreign
I guess that's the question
so so the the question the motivation
right is that they they stopped they
know they started if you look at the
time stamps right they started noticing
the
linear solver sites so a lot of these
were actually just boring ideas from
solving linear systems
and this is actually so instead of
solving the original TVD problem by
using uh yes is the difference uh maybe
solving exactly the problem versus
solving approximately the problems
disappear
exactly because you can do it much
faster
you can't
approximately
approximately maybe yes what does it
mean even much flow for example you can
do it in linear time almost
you do the exam
so it is an approx approximate version
of the problem if you're using Max flow
it's unclear how it can be the optimal
how you can claim it's an optimal
running time well I'm sure that it's an
optimal running time because it's a
generalization I use that to the main
card not much store it's not exactly the
same
and I show them yeah but if you want to
solve Min cut why not do I you know you
can you can do other things beside I
mean you can do other things you can use
linear systems to solve mean cut
that is Superior in every way
as a possibility
okay I'll look we can take this out I'll
ask you maybe we can update the future
version of the slides
but anyway this two years probably point
out they were actually approximate
methods they don't actually solve it
exactly so then we have been tired on
the other side of the camp is because
there was a lot of development in the
linear solver side as well right so
I mean most obviously people so the
point being is that the the the
computer vision Community started
noticing some of the ideas that are
coming from the theoretical communities
on solving linear systems so for example
I bring my iteration right if it's just
a pure copy of quality fixing
they're just like more or less like
transplanted some ideas to solve
matrices by fixing coordinates
okay
so now we come to the laplacian Paradigm
so we're going to talk about I think
it's been mentioned a few times around
this talk so
it's the idea is to rewrite a lot of the
problems that you have currently as
graph based problems and then you just
take the leaners we take a linear system
solver and just throw it and that's it
for that so any so you can generate a
lot of paper by Just Right showing new
runtimes that if you have a good linear
system solver you just you naturally get
a lot of good alcohol runtime so that
algorithms
so the thing is a graph are actually
discrete no sorry signals like there's
continuous signals right I actually
discrete objects right it's simply
because the physical sensors are
discrete so the way you sense them
results you
to have a discrete structure and this
discrete
structures likely vertices of a graph
and there's actually a lot of other
people talking about how do you actually
what kind of losses do you get when you
do this discrete to convince
approximation so I think Ben Ray has a
bunch of papers it's not here today but
this phenomena itself on the errors and
how do you actually do an exact
reconstruction of the continuous signal
uh the graphics approach we are talking
about today is that
and
given
some vertices that represents a noisy
signal we want to recover the
signals uh which represents the denoi
signal and then we have a bunch of like
edges that runs around and look any
other day we want to minimize some
function over the ground
okay so let's take the TV model and see
how it's being Rewritten as a graph
laplacian problem so uh let B Be The
Boundary operator so between the
vertex to the edge so if you put in a
Vertex it's easy on edge and if you want
to solve that function on top right so
effectively it's saying that we take the
boundary
of on the XSL or the Miss X is the
solutions I want to get and he has to be
small because I want the neighbors to be
small so I'll put zero for now and then
the edges that runs from X to s
this term has to be smaller too so it
gets a binary zero but you notice that
something is wrong here right because I
basically just wiped away the norms
to switch on to the next step so I kind
of like drop the L110 at the end and I
promise you I'll put in a w such that
this weighted vertices will get you the
right answers we'll see why later
and finally we hit it by its transpose
to form the laplacian so this gives you
some form of quadratic form and this is
the uh final form that we get so the
final form is
we have here The Flash and the grid the
portion which representing a grid graph
plus the identity
and your solve this linear system
right so around first of all
so intuitively the picture will be you
have a
a Greek drop which represents Your
solution space
and you have for every vertex there is
one Edge that runs into the constraint
space and then we want to solve
for the dysfunctional over this graph
so it's not exactly right because the
fact that I wiped away the L one and try
to use an L2 to solve it means there is
some Gap somewhere
so anyway this trick is pretty typical
if you do it
literature and weightedly squares so
the reason why there was a w right so
it's we wanted to re-weight it every
cycle such that the L2 will approximate
the L1
so suppose at convergence that means you
suppose you already had the the right
weights at the end of when algorithm
converges then what would it be right so
so this is the two and just the one you
go to a map is that if at convergence we
had the right Solutions then the weight
had to be satisfying this right you just
like just one over the square root of
the excess
so what is the trick here the trick here
is to
use it what we call the group lead
Square solution
so again this is we know it's not
necessarily the fastest right there are
a lot other Solutions just maybe simply
bringing books Wicks uh is way faster
than the sound project but what is cute
yeah
a couple of slides what you all discuss
this one are you talking about the
problem on the top of this page yeah
this one we need this one yeah so this
one is just one minimum cut yeah I agree
with you I know they're like a lot so
so
um this is now something different
don't you want the W inside the grid
I mean it's a weight the weights on the
edge of the bridge
then you can put you can imagine it's
stopping it as of anymore
it just means the W Pro vertex
no this one is not saying that this is
what I'm trying to say is that we can
use linear solvers in this formulation
to solve this class or problem so as to
why do you want to do that the
motivation we later down we show that
once we start writing all the problems
as graph based problem you can start mix
and matching them together and because
you have a linear solver you can
actually control the degree of solution
or the degree of progress you have I
suppose if you something like which
gives you the exact answer at the end
so we will show why you want to do that
later
so the the right this this method
converges it was proven which is giving
other you know people that we wrote in
using electrical flows
but anyway we will we don't claim we
have the fastest way of doing it but
we're just saying that doing in this
form right you have some neat
applications to show you
okay so then the other side equations
right uh which we already mentioned is
like Personal Image blending so uh it's
a very simple idea of that you put a
pass on you put a gradient field over an
image and then you have some derivation
boundary you just solve the system right
and this is formulating O3 I'm pretty
sure it was known way before that but
with that technology you can do uh image
transfer seems like you can place polar
bears and
foreign
and this
stuff I think this style of doing
Graphics as grapher in a recent year in
2013 to 2014 right you see there's a lot
of papers coming out where they want to
talk about solving graphical systems
graphs that mimics a certain computer
Graphics problem
so I claim that actually all of your
traditional image processing actually
falls into two classes from the either
they're either zero or the constraint on
the image itself if you do that you get
a
zero other constraint means that we we
fix the vertex values right so with that
you actually get compilation filters and
a bunch of filters
the way we usually think of it is like
what is a mean field mean convolution
filter over an image so it's just
basically you have like a
if you want to solve a graph where the
vertices are all connected to the
constraints right the image you're given
but there are no edges that are running
between these Solutions and you just
solve for the two norm and then
magically you get convolution filters
and there's a bunch of people that shows
a reduction of a large class of
filters into
this form the next one if you have first
up to first order constraint meaning
that you want to constrain the
differences between pixel values in
addition to the difference between these
constraints you have initially you'll
get like TV detoxing percentage blending
and so and so forth and in fact we we
produce uh sorry this bunch of results
everything using the same solver base
code and there's nothing much you need
to change actually you just need to
right you just need to generate the grid
graph and just write the function that
you want to solve and the solver takes
care of it
so why are you going to actually do this
style processing so firstly is to take
advantage of linear solvers
so so we're trying to bring together all
the different
kind of image processing problems into
one unified framework I can just throw
the
the leaness of it once I have a graph
the flashing
and the next one is to leverage on some
new graph Technologies developed by the
Big Data community so this this one is
more like there are some new
technologies like map reduce actually a
very old technology big data but we are
trying to like still some of the new
technologies that are slowly developing
in the Big Data community
so uh this one is for my my own
experience
developing some of these technology
instead this gives you a good sense of
like what energy what approach what
system approach you should take given a
graph the the problem size so anything
less than 10 gigabyte right we
discovered that if you just use like the
GPU accelerator solutions they are
pretty competitive to most of our
specifiers you have right now
and they do really silly code silly
stuff like conjugate gradient and works
the reason why is because the GPU has a
lot of calls so you're actually taking
like almost an order of magnitude of
processing calls into your problem
and
if you have something within 10 gigabyte
one Tera one terabyte it's you best use
an in-memory solution without
synchronous so they do not want to pay
the communication overhead between the
computation nodes
uh the last one is anything greater than
one terabyte you have to gun for a
asynchronous display solution so if any
of you developing like really really
loud solvers these are the like sort of
like the steps that you want to take
the reason why is one terabyte
Cletus
what you can get off the shelf these
days what four uh bought with four
months before CPUs
and they have 16 wrecks and each other
and put in a few but
so I see so you're saying that the GPU
based things can contain
for these sizes
again
but in principle many of the many of the
you know basic operations inside Sims it
can be done it is Matrix modification
cannot be used
next slide so if you want to use Matrix
knob you must use the GPU somewhere to
be competitive these days
so so even though even though we're
developing like theoretical solvers
right once you implementing code like
any kind of a sequential CP will lose
the GPU like straight up for Matrix more
it's not also true for Sparks graphs
that you can have good implementations
on GPU yes yes because you know I I
talked to a lot of people who told me no
but I believe yes it's possible you can
do very fast yeah
yeah okay because that's given a good
order holography can you do it yeah
so in this this was actually surprising
because the 2004 hyperlex paper you saw
just now let's start even though they
have a really large system right they're
still using conjugate gradients and they
run through like run times like a few
hours to solve the cube itself
which we know can be definitely done a
lot faster
the last one is about this one was
actually mentioned by the IBM group they
were doing the
so one of the problems that we usually
don't talk about in this community is
that even though we want to solve the
system right the system itself needs
data and data has to be pre-positioned
beforehand
meaning is like you cannot assume that
if you're a distributor over a few
computers right that every machine has
the global view of all the data
does that make sense because what
happens that most of the time 80 of your
overhead is actually doing data copying
so all the live map reduce stuff right
even though it takes like maybe a few
minutes to compute but you spend like
one hour copying all the data the one
terabyte of data across the different
machines
so it's best that if you have uh if you
write solo code red and it does like at
every Parallel level there's some means
to
bring the data locally and not require a
off machine query
and that will like burn away all your
runtime quickly
so now now the idea of why when you use
graphics and examples
if you have no ones repopulate like TV
denoising spectral segmentation person
blending as graph problems right you can
see they naturally fall into the same
form and then you can use one data
structure which is your graph laplacian
many many times over and over solve
different problems not only that you can
just throw a bunch of like LaGrange
multipliers and that controls
the different rate of different
algorithms they're using
and you have a solver right it allows
you to control the degree of solving the
problem itself so why is this useful so
first one is like we talk about spectral
segmentation this was some work with one
of carries students here so the goal is
to like try to segment cells inside I
think maybe it was a lung tissue or
something trying to get the cells out
but we know a scenery a few times like
spectral cementation don't really tend
to do well
it's kind of set up
right so what we did was that we we kind
of like tricked the speculation
algorithm we just throw in the PVD now
at the side and that gut is the spectral
simulation are going to get the right
segmentation
and this can be done because we wrote
that as a graph program right and if you
do it in the traditional sense you have
to like deny first then use your segment
by our case we could like
the noise as you segment
because it was formulated in the same
framework
so this so that helps to do better
segmentation on the right so this is if
you just do TV device this is what you
get yeah
okay the next application is on it's all
my friends it is some kind of
regularization yeah during the
dissolution process right and but uh I
didn't understand the what was the
advantage of looking at it this way I
mean just because you can
you can keep the you know you can solve
the system while you regularize the
whole time yes so right now you have
agreed right you just you want to have a
cut that runs across but every time you
try to make a cut then you can run one
cycle of denoising by trying to reduce
the the H jumps
simultaneously can do both algorithm in
one go and that allows you to and you
just put in some of the garage
multiplier you can control how much of
which algorithm appears in the final
solution
and the next one is a
this is like camouflage detection so
this was a picture by some U.S company
that claimed they have like some Optical
stealth technology
so well actually if you compute the this
picture really makes it's a bit hard to
understand but what happens that when
you are trying to solve the TV noise and
you control these step sizes you can
actually find the jumps
you can find different scales or jumps
right so if you can see right this area
here there's like two patches of
variation and there's a small country
but basically the thing is that you can
control how fast your Venus always
moving and that actually gives you some
new insights of what's going on in the
image and that allows you to actually
detect the brain and so there's a very
very small break that's going on in the
texture that gives you this ability type
camouflage
to the code
this one is Shadow retrieval so this one
is I think it's more impressive if the
guy is
but the back the the other end you
detects the other end as well
yeah it's more impressive if you if if
the guy is not holding it open right can
you do this
so if you actually retrieve the solution
you can actually see the person's body
the person is like lying in this
direction
yeah
so you analyze like the if you Analyze
This or which I didn't I mean that would
be another computer vision talk on how
to detect that but you can actually see
the person's of also inside
okay so so we're going to talk about how
this actually works for you so next
Line's on Shadow retriever uh so in in
satellite imaging right so the tall
building fans with card shadows and then
blocks it so there's actually some means
to recover this so if you do your
favorite Adobe you just throw like some
of the latest
enhancement to it they don't really get
very good results I don't have enough
information to see
now there is enough information but just
that traditional signal processing that
does somehow local base it doesn't
actually give you that good result so
well you might not believe that this is
actually better but you can really see a
bit more detail and this is
done using both TVD and the person image
itself and the reason why we don't pass
on slight Halo right now is because this
is a single Channel image so the actual
technology that we develop uses
multi-spectral data that allows you
actually do that allows you to see
better into the shadow but again this is
we can do this is because we combine a
few graph problems and put them together
yeah
you can't see there are more objects
here but this is a much higher
resolution picture here this is zoom in
to see
foreign
and this this is actually the main
motivation for my line of work is that
these images are really big so a
satellite image typically is about
this one is really small
but the typical one is about one
gigabyte and they
so we want something that we have to be
able to process everything
within like five minutes
so this is actually what motivates most
of the world so the conclusion is that
the data generated from our sensors
today in the near future will outpace
all the methods of processing
efficiently using the current current
approaches
and what we can do is we reformulate
this image person in terms as graph
based problem and then we can take
advantage of the new linear solvers and
the new graph technology
also the last point is actually quite
important that like there's actually
lots of room and uh room for r d for
image processing using graph solvers so
one advantage that images and signals
have is that their graphs are really
the self uh graphs right are really
small there they either agreed or killed
or some
like the one you saw in hyperlapse is a
line graph with some small
uh fully connected component so
what I'm trying to say is that maybe if
you cannot solve the general class of
problem let's just try to solve this
small graph this more set and we get
very good speed up and we have some nice
tools to use but the cube is very
different from the grid oh the cube is
very different thank you
because you know it's much smaller
because the grid is playing
anymore
yeah a new tool to sell yeah okay
that's all for my top
I still would say one woman compare this
to the performance of an optimization
alloy so if you're back in optimize
solution and gloss is good enough or
maybe even better quality in terms of
whatever you want to achieve then the
optimize solution that just means that
the objective function that you set up
in the sales place is not the right one
but if you had the right objective
function and you want to solve it why
not run it in the same amount of time as
the optimization algorithm and compare
the results
that I just don't see how you can oh my
God
and I'm going that is very efficient in
practice it's solved problems on a sale
of a
billion
edges in the graph and it should be in
under a minute and that was few years
ago so today you can do it a lot more
efficiently
goodbye and uh so you know my question
will be in your framework how many
problems can you like compose them
together
is it possible to write like denoising
segmentation and a bunch of problems
together one major system
I'm not sure what you may
to make terms that you are showing no no
but that was only one of the graphs one
of the image processing problems I
wanted to solve right so so you can
think of it as like I want yes I have an
mrf for this mrf I still want to find
some
like I want to constrain like maybe half
of maybe some values and I still want to
do some composition of a bunch of tasks
on it so once you get into that scenario
then I'm not sure how your MRI would
look like and we really do not really
know how
if the formulations two holes
wait
um well I'll agree with you that if we
do
so this service center is um
approximations yeah yeah always the
approximations end up looking like Marco
random things
and that one they solve these techniques
of similar flavor to what you're sure
not necessarily using linear service but
iterative techniques that are not exact
and hopefully they convert to the
Optimal Solutions
but if you have so once you do the
transformation and you come up with the
formulation there is fitting into the
framework of Marco Antonio
is very general the functions that you
showed on that slide well particular
function well for deviation equals
quadratic and for the separation it was
absolute value this is just no problem
at all I agree with you I agree with you
that yeah on the other ones I I have a
paper in which I gave a whole list of of
those that are using in the literature
and how to discretize them and how
people have discretized them and how we
can sort them more efficiently in the
market setup so it's not I I don't
understand that's your system
automatically formulate the problem no
it doesn't
so so what exactly is the advantage but
the simplest of all problems is given a
graph in two points s and t find me a
small Edge cut that problem supposedly
there's famous papers coming out of here
and MIT and these others which get near
linear times
let me just finish my sentence so if for
some reason you'd already solved that
problem you should go back and complain
to them and don't worry about us because
they're getting major credits for being
able to do the SD cut problem
your time and if you're claiming you
already have an optical algorithm for it
why mess around talking to us you should
go tell them that they that they should
pull their paper I don't understand
oh no because this is a that's a special
case of what all he's doing
I asked earlier if the idea is to solve
this particular formulation because this
particular formulation is a cut
procedure and therefore whatever applies
to cut with linear systems applies and
that's fine that's totally fine but I
ask if this is the contribution I told
me no that this is something more
genuine than that yeah so so the
contribution is like if you look at this
whole series over by Microsoft right
like this set of work this set of work
and the hyperlapse right they all have
different
growth problems
they all have like maybe every single of
the technology they have a different
girlfriend when they set up and they use
a different solver for every problem
itself but what I'm saying is that a lot
of this problem is think hard about it
right you can actually rewrite them into
the one single linear system and that's
it
I think definitely at least there's a
there's a sense in which you know uh one
nice motivation for this is you write
down the problem which is a Min cut
problem and then you know that you can
solve now we know that you can solve the
main Cuts using electrical flows right
right so this is uh at least a
motivation for why one might even
consider electrical Flows In This
framework right right you have a slide
which does this laplacian relaxation but
in some sense I mean this is uh this
came out of thinner and at least one
thing is that it did you know I mean a
very clear motivation is that you're
trying to solve a Min cut problem and
you know and now we know how to solve
minicuts using electrical flows wow yeah
that's it essentially the skillet
although it's not exactly mean practice
parametric mean cut it's not clear to me
how the linear solve that's parametric
clinical but that would be fine I mean
to study how it works that it's totally
good but now you're not doing any
comparison to this thing so I don't know
why this is good performance what you
allow what you're presenting with I
don't know in what sense it's epoxy mate
and I don't know in what sense it's fast
I mean you can do nothing and then you
make the fastest algorithm possible
which is of course in making some sense
also can't be because otherwise all
these poor kids that did this other
paper they you know they're gonna have
to quit because you know it would have
already been done
so you know you have to go back and say
hey I have chatty Pepe her paper is
about reducing to midnight tea cup
her paper is reducing the buffer random
field to end to St couple for amazing
yeah yeah so two problem is different
yeah yeah and in that sense it's optimal
it shows it's
parametric and this is for this
particular objective function this
objective function is only like one of
2500 of like the hundreds of those that
we try to complete other ones it's a
little bit more elabor way
so it depends if the separation function
you're keeping is absolute value any
context function is still parametric
minimum Cup and the running time is the
fastest possible in the sense that it
generalizes minimum cut and it
generalizes funding zero of the convex
functions and the running time is
exactly the sum of these two terms and
in practice I implemented it it is
exactly the same objective function that
you showed and I was able to
address problems where they the type of
problems that I got paid up to
16.9 million pixels and I was able to do
it very fast so in practice it works
well so I'm now wondering and and there
is also I showed how Adele
a type of TV
problems can be cast as much of random
fields and therefore sold
I don't know if to say more efficiently
because no one is actually solved it
exactly before but now you're proposing
a bunch of things they are fine but now
in what sense is this better not real to
me okay I'm looking for collaborators to
work with offline and traffic how we can
work together
okay any other questions
process and segmentation yeah so
can you apply your idea on Instagram
images
so then you can solve the uh
okay
I I think you can if you already know
the decomposition function which is your
inverse order transfer function you
should be able to deconvolve and similar
to go
because the convolution is equivalent to
some zero order transform on your
vertices only
here you as you said that you're you
know you're concerned say with a grid
graph yeah but you're as far as I
understand you're using these general
purpose solvers
I'm just
but I'm saying that in the industry you
know I actually use a CMV or anywhere
so in your undergraduate thesis you also
used a non-local methods right where you
tied together pixels that were further
apart so you know overlay the graph but
you're no longer using those options uh
or they didn't work that was just uh
because it was another talk here by you
and she she was adding the complete
graph over the top and she found that
very useful
she was doing variants of that yeah so I
mean and so and I think at Stella you I
think was adding on you know an
arbitrary random you know graph
but I think a lot of this problem is
actually with the solver not normally
the only reason to say that is because
then it you know as soon as you've added
a random graph to your grid graph it's
no longer a grid and then you have to
figure out what you're going to do right
right right I'm I'm just I'm just
curious I mean I I talk to people who
are doing things that like I mean in
nanotechnology simulation where they
have a grid but then because of some
Quantum effects they also have to
contract some substances of notes and
I'm just sort of wondering at which
point one expects that sort of general
purpose solvers uh
so so my experience is that the general
purpose solvers are useful for doing
experimentation like trying to figure
out what's the general flow of the
algorithm but once you're done you have
a good idea of what you want right then
people tend to just switch over to
Dedicated solvers where they design
specifically for their class or problems
so in our case right we actually have
for example when trying to solve the
very large satellite image we do the
grids for experimentation now that we
run some sort of like nested dissection
to solve the entire grid
here again